on prépare le tunnel pour l'entrave
majeur à côté du 31 octobre on est dans
le tunnel qui va servir à la circulation
le tunnel où Hippolyte la fontaine en
direction de Montréal se met en mode
travaux majeur le compte à rebours a
commencé dans une semaine la circulation
sera plus restreinte que jamais
seulement deux voix en direction de
Montréal et une voie vers la Rive-Sud
seront ouverte il va avoir des flèches
l'objectif de ces flèches là c'est de
faire en sorte que les gens respectent
une distance plus importante dans chaque
véhicule la recommandation sera de 30
mètres de distance entre les véhicules
ce qui correspondra à la distance de
deux flèches peintes au sol et comme
d'habitude il faudra allumer les phares
du véhicule
ça va servir ça va être des
anti-éblouissement donc pour contresens
des phares des véhicules donc pour
réduire la lumière et l'éblouissement le
des conducteurs ces éléments-là étaient
mises en place selon Transport Québec il
y a annuellement une centaine
d'incidents dans le tunnel Louis Polyte
Lafontaine et ses approches l'année
dernière de ce nombre 3 en cause des
incendies
est muni de cabinet incendie donc un
réseau d'eau à l'intérieur même du
tunnel auquel les pompiers vont se
brancher et ils vont utiliser les
cabinets sans dit des pompiers dédiés à
la sécurité du tunnel sont en poste 24
heures sur 24 avec un équipement
spécialisé tant pour l'extérieur que
l'intérieur c'est des unités électriques
sont situées à l'intérieur du corridor
d'évacuation dans lequel les pompiers
prennent place ils se dirigent là selon
la situation et l'endroit à l'intérieur
du tunnel des véhicules adaptés aux
espaces exiguës et au déplacement
efficace dans un corridor la
particularité du véhicule c'est des
véhicules on est conduite aux deux aux
deux extrémités parce qu'on se retrouve
bientôt dans un corridor donc quand ça
vient le temps de tourner c'est pas
toujours très évident et c'est toujours
une question de temps les travaux de
réflexion de cet axe routier névralgique
dans la région métropolitaine sont
prévus sichelonner sur 3 ans donc les
gens doivent vraiment regarder leurs
options et changer la façon qui vont se
déplacer soit en transport collectif
soit en quittant plutôt ou plus tard
soit faire davantage de télétravail voir
quels sont les options qui vont leur
permettre de faciliter leur ville
faciliter la vie tout en y intégrant une
bonne dose de patience